In these videos I want to start thinking
for the different ways in which molecules
can pass through the cell membrane
outwards or downwards
inside out.
The first type of transport of molecules through the membranes,
which I'm going to talk about is transport,
which does not require energy.
With it the molecules move in the direction
of its concentration gradient.
We call this mode passive.
Passive transport.
He does not use energy.
Simply molecules move in the direction
of its concentration gradient.
I will write it, "They move in the direction of their concentration gradient."
Toward
the concentration gradient.
If we have this cell membrane,
many things can move
in the direction of its concentration gradient.
But this membrane has selective permeability.
It will be less permeable for
certain types of molecules.
Consider the different types of molecules
and how they can pass passively
through the membrane.
If we had very small molecules, we can say,
"Well, they can pass through the spaces
between hydrophilic heads,
may fit in the spaces
between hydrophilic tails and through the membrane. "
So it's good for them to be small.
If you are small, it helps transport, passive transport,
promotes diffusion through the membrane.
More precisely, it is good to be
small and unladen.
Small and unladen.
An example of such a molecule is carbon dioxide.
Carbon dioxide is a small molecule
without charge.
So if the molecules carbon dioxide
have a higher concentration from the outside,
than in the inside of the cage - actually, do it upside down.
Let's say we have a higher concentration in the cell's interior,
from outside.
As we learned in the video about diffusion,
after a certain time
we will have more molecules of carbon dioxide, which
pass from the inside of the cell and interact with the membrane,
of carbon dioxide molecules that interact with the membrane on the outside.
Of course they have no charge
will not be attracted
of the hydrophilic heads of the phospholipids,
but they will not be repulsed by them either.
On the inside there will be more molecules that interact
with the membrane on the outside.
And as they are small,
some of them will pass through the membrane.
They will not worry about them
hydrophobic tails.
There will be movement of carbon dioxide molecules in both directions,
but there will be more molecules going inside
outside as far as the outside.
They will move in the direction of
its concentration gradient.
Therefore, carbon dioxide can pass
easily by diffusion through the cell membranes.
Another such molecule is that of oxygen.
Oxygen molecules can easily pass through diffusion
through the cell membranes.
If we have a higher concentration
of oxygen outside, than you turn away,
since the oxygen molecule is small and uncharged,
it will not have any problems with transport.
Will not be attracted to
hydrophilic heads,
but since it is small, it will be able to pass
between them,
they will be indifferent to them.
Then he will be able to pass
between hydrophilic tails
and since it has a higher concentration from outside,
than on the inside,
after a while
there will be more random interactions in the direction from the outside to the inside,
than in the direction from the inside out.
Therefore, as a whole, we will have oxygen transport to the inside of the cell.
These molecules will naturally be transported
by diffusion.
They will be on their way
the structure made up of all these molecules,
which make up the cell membrane,
but they will be able to go through it.
And what happens to things they will have
many transport problems?
Things that will make it difficult for them to pass through the membrane,
are, for example, sodium ions.
Sodium ion.
Either potassium ion.
Why would they have difficulty going through the membrane?
Let's think.
Let's say we have a higher concentration
of sodium ions from outside,
than on the inside.
They can be attracted to hydrophilic heads,
which have a charge,
but there is no reason to want
to continue after that.
They will be attracted by hydrophilic heads,
which have a charge,
while hydrophobic tails have nothing to interest them.
They may want to climb
about phosphate heads,
but they will not be able to migrate all the way through the membrane.
Therefore particles that are loaded have
passive diffusion problem.
In the next videos we will see that there are other ways,
which they can go through.
There are protein channels,
which provide them with transport tunnels.
We'll talk about that.
But natural diffusion will be difficult
for particles like these.
Well, particles that are somewhere in the middle.
Like these water molecules for example?
Water is extremely important,
because the cells live in an aquatic environment.
They are surrounded by water inside and
outside.
Water is the middle between the ions and the neutral molecules,
because there is no full charge,
but partial.
Water = oxygen + 2 x hydrogen.
Oxygen likes to attract electrons.
There is a partial negative charge at this end.
And the hydrogen atoms have
partial positive charge.
Partial positive charge at this end.
We call these phosphate heads hydrophilic,
because they are attracted to the water
and the water is attracted to them.
So the water molecules definitely
will be attracted
to hydrophilic heads.
But their charge is not so strong.
If there are enough interactions,
many water molecules will be attracted,
but some of them will be able to pass through the membrane.
The water molecule is small enough,
and its charge is not strong enough.
We can say it's polar,
but it will pass through the membrane.
Not as easy as carbon dioxide and oxygen,
but will slowly pass through diffusion.
As we shall see, there are other ways
this transport can be facilitated
and the water can pass.
We will see in the next videos that there are things like aquaporins -
tunnels through the membranes,
so water does not have to deal with
with all this here.
And of course, if we have big molecules,
if we have such a large protein,
he will have difficulty with transport.
There will be problems.
It will be difficult for him to physically pass
through the spaces in the membrane, not to mention its parts,
which are hydrophobic or hydrophilic.
I hope this video gave you an idea of ​​the things that can pass
through the cell membrane by diffusion.
It is a type of passive transport,
in the next video
we will talk about relieved passive transport.